[Music]
the power of an ice storm
the mess the misery and the hundreds of
thousands in the dark in Ontario and
Quebec on this Thursday night
new details about the death of an
indigenous woman found in a Winnipeg
landfill but police have discovered
about her final moments
David Johnston's mandate what powers the
former Governor General has been given
to investigate foreign interference and
haunting memories of the Humboldt
Broncos tragedy a semi truck was coming
our way and everything was black how
family and friends are doing five years
after the crash
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with severe weather and the
impact of a major ice storm in central
Canada more than one million customers
are without power after freezing rain
coated trees and power lines across a
big swath of Southern Ontario and Quebec
the rain and Ice has led to flooding in
some areas and at least one person is
dead struck by a falling tree prime
minister Justin Trudeau surveyed the
damage today in his Montreal riding
our focus is very much on on being there
to support as necessary municipalities
and uh and the province uh as necessary
the federal government uh is is here to
help if needed
hundreds of hydro crews are busy across
both provinces working to restore a
power as fast as possible but people are
being warned there are so many lines to
repair it will take time and they should
be prepared to spend another night or
more without electricity Mike Armstrong
has our top story tonight
people
first there's how things got to this
point
Wednesday freezing rain fell for hours
by midday it was knocking out Power
by late afternoon it was taking down
trees
close calls for some
for others a feeling things were almost
surreal towards evening like seven
o'clock night time it was just like a
war zone trees branches were cracking
and falling it was like everywhere loud
loud very loud sounds like gunshots
almost
the rain left a thick layer of ice
basically on everything the problem was
weight
every Branch was heavier and not all of
them could take it hydroquoback
estimates there are close to 2 700
repairs to be made and as more than a
thousand people out working but the
premier is asking for patience we expect
that tomorrow night at midnight we'll
have 70 to 80 percent of the population
that will have electricity back now
Hydro Quebec is
it they just couldn't
so the freezing rain stopped it meant as
the problem got bigger Crews waited some
teams were on the field watching this
tuition but most of the work we could
only start this morning
repair crews are now being deployed
based on where they can make the biggest
impact they're fixing brakes that will
return power to the biggest number of
people first now complicating everything
is that in some areas cell phones don't
work the storm-affected towers meaning
there's no access to the internet or
Communications when Crews and the public
need it most it's not fun I can't
contact anybody not my parents not my
friends nobody it's also meant
scrambling to find the few stores that
are open can't call ahead to check yes
this is my third stop you found one yeah
I finally found one I think I haven't
walked up yet it's nothing to compare to
98. this storm has many people
remembering another the 1998 ice storm
the big difference is that one lasted
longer five days instead of one and it
affected transmission towers the lines
that carry power to Cities In This Storm
it's the smaller distribution lines that
are affected
now there has been one death a man west
of Montreal who was cutting a tree when
a branch fell and killed him Hydro
Quebec is asking people to leave jobs
like that to professionals Donna
good advice Mike Armstrong in Montreal
thanks
system kept moving East and hit Atlantic
Canada overnight causing sporadic power
outages and treacherous driving
conditions in some areas a number of
schools in the maritimes were closed
this morning though the freezing rain
has now transitioned to rain this was a
far-reaching storm system that stretched
Beyond Canada's border Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell is with me
Anthony put this into context for us
Donna when you think April you don't
often associate it with ice storms but
it can occur when the ingredients are
right and that's just what we had for
this widespread event that extended
through eastern Ontario Quebec and as
you mentioned right into the maritimes
all day yesterday there was Heavy
freezing rain there were lightning
strikes in this region as well and all
of this moisture associated with the
storm that also brought tornadoes to the
Southern United States but this is the
difference this Arctic High over North
Eastern Quebec funneling up the St
Lawrence Valley that low-level cold air
that you need for freezing rain event it
also went into the Ottawa Valley so
that's where the amounts were heaviest
locally as high as 30 to 35 millimeters
of ice accretion and I was in Montreal
for the 1998 ice storm the triangle of
Darkness that was on the South Shore
that was where the heaviest totals were
that time this time it's right over
Montreal now that seems to be the worst
of it the good news is that once we get
through this next threat which is some
strong winds tomorrow up to 60
kilometers per hour we are into a
pattern change that's going to affect
basically much of Canada spring is
arriving this weekend next week well
above seasonal temperatures Donna all
right Anthony Farnell thank you in the
U.S a string of devastating tornadoes
and Powerful storms have ripped across
the country in recent weeks according to
the U.S national weather service there
have been at least 478 tornado reports
this year across 25 States that's double
the average for this time of year and
tonight some 40 million Americans remain
under severe weather warnings Jennifer
Johnson reports
Americans are bracing for another round
of wicked weather and a year that's on
track to be one of the worst in history
the statistics are staggering at least
478 tornadoes so far have been reported
across 25 States Glen Allen will never
be the same there's no doubt about it
this community about two hours south of
St Louis Missouri was leveled residents
are returning to their homes finding
little more than piles of rubble I was
praying hoping that we would get through
it all right and everybody else would
because just the way just how strong you
could feel the wind against the bathroom
wall it was just unbelievable that fence
is gone over there this week tornadoes
left a trail of Destruction from Iowa
South and Arkansas across the Midwest
and as far east as Delaware and more are
coming hundreds of flights across the
country are delayed or canceled this
vicious weather shocking even the
experts I've never seen a windier year
ever ever in my life in Louisville
Kentucky an entire apartment building
was torn up displacing all who lived
here states are turning to the federal
government for Aid as losses pile up
well into the billions when you look at
the devastation of this it's going to be
weeks upon months to be able to recover
uh it's a long journey ahead for the
people that live here
thousands have lost everything
volunteers are trying to help in any way
they can hundreds in Arkansas are still
needing basic necessities like food
after devastating tornadoes there we did
1800 hot dog meals for everybody
and we're just now getting ready and
getting pumped for dinner which is 900
chicken
sandwiches over the past two weeks more
than 60 people have died in tornadoes in
the U.S that's nearly triple the number
this time last year and the typically
turbulent spring has just begun
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
Winnipeg Police have released new
details about an indigenous woman whose
body was found in a landfill on Monday
police considered the death of
33-year-old Linda beardy suspicious but
after tips from the public including
Witnesses who say they saw her climb
into a garbage bin they now say there is
no evidence to suggest her death was a
homicide
so an autopsy was conducted on April 4th
and it confirmed that the injuries that
the body sustained were consistent with
that of a truck handling of the bin
there were no other injuries that
suggest any kind of Foul Play
police say video surveillance showed
beardy climbing into the garbage bin
alone her body was later discovered at
the landfill her family said in a
statement today they are devastated and
heartbroken
the day after police and City Crews
moved in to clear a tent encampment on
Vancouver's downtown east side some
people have already returned and many
say they have nowhere else to go and
coover is not the only city dealing with
unhoused people it's an issue across
North America As Cities grapple with
inadequate housing and shelter plus the
skyrocketing cost of living Nitro garcha
reports on how Vancouver is trying to
deal with the problem this time and why
Advocates say it's not enough
police have corded off a few blocks of
Vancouver's downtown east side and Tents
have popped back up in the same location
where there was a mass eviction the day
before what they're doing in the last 48
hours
is really hurtful to our to the people
on intensity because where are you gonna
put them
where is the city put in
hiding them the rapid escalation in the
decampment I think caught a lot of us by
surprise an estimated 100 people are
seeking shelter the city says it can't
commit to offering enough spaces and
non-profits in the area say many of
their spaces are also full do they end
up in adjoining neighborhoods
and then what is the impact on those
neighborhoods Community Advocate Stephen
Johnston says the evictions have put
those displaced at more risk and he's
pushing for a steady secure supply of
housing
um if it's not working they don't
realize it's not working I guess I don't
know
because they're not the ones down here
talking to everyone the why did
Vancouver Police and City staff choose
to move in on the neighborhood now local
officials point to a lack of Public
Safety the longer the East Hastings
encampment continues the greater odds
that more people will lose their lives
and even more people will lose their
homes more than two times a day a person
is being assaulted in the encampment and
approximately one-third of the assaults
are serious assaults or involve a weapon
it's one of the city's oldest
neighborhoods a community of communities
which struggles with poverty mental
illness substance use and addiction
Johnston calls it a crisis stemming from
a history of constant displacement we
had Expo 86 where a number of residents
were evicted from sros uh you know I
would call it the first mass renovation
far from the first decampment in the
city it's a familiar scene with no easy
solution
Global News Vancouver
the RCMP has arrested two women with
suspected ties to Isis who have been
brought back from Syria they're among
the group of women and children who just
returned to Canada after spending years
in a detention camp in Northeast Syria
the crown is requesting a terrorism
peace bond for the two women which would
mean they'd have to live under certain
conditions for up to a year Global
Affairs confirms four mothers and 10
children were repatriated yesterday a
court ordered Canada bring back six
Canadian women from the camp at the
repatriation did Naco as planned two of
the women never got on the plane and are
now missing
the federal government has laid out what
powers former Governor General David
Johnston will have to investigate
foreign interference in Canada No Limits
have been put on whom he can talk to in
the course of his work Mackenzie gray is
with me from Ottawa McKenzie the terms
of his job really matter because he can
only investigate what he's given access
to so start with what exactly he's being
asked to do yeah Don David Johnson's
been given a broad mandate to look into
allegations of foreign interference
during the last two elections and one of
the biggest things he'll take a look at
is what Justin Trudeau in his office
knew about these allegations and another
key thing he'll review what the prime
minister's office did or didn't do to
address any of the alleged interference
and that's a really important Point
Donna because we've asked the Prime
Minister on a number of times what he
knew and when he learned about these
allegations and he's never really given
a clear answer on things like when he
was briefed or what info he had now Mr
Johnson will also review what kind of
information was shared between
departments like csis the RCMP and the
prime minister's office to see if
important info made it to where it was
supposed to go and to wrap it all up
Donna Johnston will give recommendations
to the Prime Minister about how to
handle interference in upcoming
elections and Mackenzie what about
access National Security concerns and
cabinet confidence limits what can be
made public but will Johnston get to see
that stuff yeah he's going to be able to
review the classified documents and
files that are covered by cabinet
conference so he should have a pretty
good understanding about what the
government knew but it's important for
Canadians to know just because Johnson
gets to see that information doesn't
mean it's going to go public so unless
cabinet confidence is waived and the
classified documents are Declassified by
the Prime Minister Johnston wouldn't be
able to share the kind of details that
are in those files when he issues his
reports and when those reports are come
out isn't exactly clear either all the
order and Council says that he'll
provide rolling updates with those
reports but there is one key date that
we do know Donna it's May 23rd and
that's when Johnson's going to make his
decision for the Prime Minister on
whether or not to call a public inquiry
into electoral interference okay
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
the latest jobs numbers are out and they
exceed what many economists were
anticipating given inflation and
interest rates Canada's economy added
nearly 35 000 jobs in March the seventh
consecutive month of gains the national
jobless rate held steady at a near
record low of 5 percent for a fourth
month in a row virtually all the jobs
added were in the private sector the
biggest gains in transportation and
warehousing the average hourly wage is
up just over five percent from last year
Help Wanted on the farm coming up the
shortage of agricultural workers and
what that could mean for all of us
on the one hand low unemployment is a
good thing on the other hand Canada's
labor market continues to be extremely
tight there are staff shortages in just
about every sector agriculture is being
hit especially hard and as Farmers age
and retire there are few people lining
up to replace them and gaviola looks at
what that could mean
there's Help Wanted on nearly every Farm
across Canada and the shortage is poised
to get much worse according to new
research by RBC this is placing the
sector on the cusp of one of the most
transformative labor transitions uh in
this country's history 40 percent of
Canadian farmers are set to retire by
2033 and 66 percent of producers don't
have a succession plan which leaves the
future of Farmland up in the air within
the next three decades the labor
shortfall in the agricultural industry
is set to hit 24 000 workers there are
many solutions to this multifaceted
problem including immigration with an
eye on the skills needed in the
agriculture sector automation is another
way to address the labor shortage by
using robots to perform the most
dangerous and physically taxing jobs
montreal-based Nexus robotics is
commercializing machines that pull weeds
from vegetable crops company founder
tarek greenen says drawing more people
into careers in agriculture is also
important I ended up traveling across
Canada after leaving engineering school
and really fell in love with Agriculture
and specifically agricultural systems
experts say more people need to consider
farming as a career to ensure Canada's
food security and keep food inflation
from spiraling it doesn't matter what
background you have you can still be
involved in the sector and I think
that's what needs to be encouraged more
across universities across the country I
am hoping that there is more
encouragement for City kids like myself
to participate in this industry because
it's not going away anytime soon proof
that Innovative Minds can find new
solutions to problems plaguing the
industry and gaviola Global News Toronto
fiery reaction ahead lebanon's
retaliation after Israeli police raided
Jerusalem mosque again
[Music]
the situation continues to escalate in
Israel after a second raid by Israeli
police on Jerusalem's Alexa mosque
Israel says its Army intercepted dozens
of rockets fired from Lebanon
the IDF says most of the Rockets were
intercepted and no deaths were reported
it's a response to the hundreds of
Palestinians arrested and in some cases
beaten at the Al-Aqsa mosque during the
holy month of Ramadan Israeli police
claim they had to launch the raids
because people armed with sticks and
fireworks had locked themselves in the
mosque and refused to leave
in France public outrage continues weeks
after president Emmanuel macron's
government passed controversial pension
reforms
[Music]
more violent clashes with police broke
out as large crowds of demonstrators
made their way through Paris today part
of another round of Nationwide protests
people are demanding macron resign and
withdraw Wildland popular reforms that
raise the retirement age from 62 to 64.
at one point protesters Set Fire to the
front of a bistro no one as one of
macron's favorites
the French President is on a state visit
to China and today Yale talks with the
Chinese president Xi Jinping before the
meeting mackrell said he knew he could
count on the Chinese leader to bring
Russia back to reason McCall's under
pressure from the U.S to use the visit
to dissuade China from forging closer
ties with Russia macron did say France
and China agreed nuclear weapons should
be excluded from the conflict she said
China and France had the ability and
responsibility to safeguard World Peace
Reflections on the Humboldt Broncos
tragedy next the lives lost and the
lives forever changed five years later
it was so devastating when it happened
five years ago it's almost hard to put
into words at an intersection in rural
Saskatchewan the bus carrying the
Humboldt Broncos hockey team to a
playoff game was hit by a semi-trailer
truck 16 people were killed 13 others
injured those Left Behind the families
and the injured have been coping with
the consequences ever since Nathaniel
Dove spoke to some of them about how
they're marking this painful anniversary
I heard a scream from the front of the
bus I looked and instantly a semi truck
was coming our way and everything was
black five years ago Canada stopped
shocked by what happened on a northern
Saskatchewan Highway yeah definitely had
those moments where you know I let I let
grief kind of take over my day and ruin
it for myself and I guess the people
around me Ryan strechnitzky one of 13
humble Broncos injured 16 died like
trainer Dana bronze every one of these
gifts has a story in a gallery
surrounded by tokens of support from
around the world her mother Carol bronze
like the others says it doesn't feel
like five years
it just feels like a hole still in our
in our lives sometimes the sea is calm
and the next day this there's a storm
and you get hit by the wave I went to
seven funerals in eight days
that's not supposed to happen those who
spoke to Global News say they still
haven't made sense of what happened of
the lives forever changed and lost
they move forward because they have to
trying to honor the memories of their
teammates and loved ones
Toby and Bernadine boulay lost their son
Logan in the crash they now Champion
green shirt day to promote organ
donation inspired by their son's
decision after we walked Logan to the
operating room we left the hospital and
as we were walking down this hallway
there was a man coming with a cart
with coolers and the you knew that the
coolers where they were going and what
they were being used for they all say
they'll Mark the anniversary and the
days after when others died quietly
they hope Canada does the same that we
remember our loved ones and those who
need help
moving ahead
because what else can you do we can't
control a lot of the things that happen
to us we can only control what happens
after Nathaniel Dove Global News
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is kluani Lake in Yukon we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching nithu garchow will be at
the anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see
you Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]
thank you